on wednesday parliamentarians will
choose a successor to gotabe rajapaksa
who fled the country and resigned amid
massive public protests as the vote
approaches the deal making is intense
garud
dallas the opposition leader pulled out
of the race and proposed former
government minister dallas alha peruma
the chairman of the rajapaksa's slpp
party seconded the name
of another senior slpp member proposed
ranil vikramasingha for the post
second was this man who had been a
vociferous critic
vikrama singha has been premier six
times and is now the acting president
he's a familiar figure but not a popular
one
seen as a protector of the rajapaksas he
is likely to have their support
this man is his main challenger dallas
peruma a senior politician sidelined by
the rajapaksa brothers
he first entered parliament in 1994.
a few years later he said he was
disheartened and disgusted but after a
break from politics he's back in the
field
the third candidate is anurakumara
desanaka the leader of the national
people's force
his party mobilized tens of thousands of
people from across sri lanka to march
against the rajapaksa government and
vikrama singha
[Applause]
the outcry over the possibility of ranil
vikramasingha being elected is getting
louder university students joined trade
unions to voice their opposition on
monday
right now ranilli is doing a deal
politics we know don't need deal
politics we need politics better
politics please go home
again
how can someone fully rejected by the
people be chosen as the president of the
country that's why we are totally
opposed to this
a state of emergency was declared by the
acting president on sunday giving police
and military wider powers to arrest
detain and hold protesters ban
gatherings and crack down on dissent
but protesters say they won't be
intimidated
the reality of sri lankan politics
rivaling the best fiction you can read
a man who was voted in with a whopping
six nine million votes to become
president forced to leave the country
among public protests
and a man who is trying to become his
successor who is thrown out of
parliament
the sri lankan people hope
that their wishes will be respected when
the choice is made mine fernandez al
jazeera colombo